I built my own Zenesk and I did in three
days.
>> Do you think people will use
conversational chat like chat GPT
experience in your CRM?
>> You tell to the AI, hey, this is what I
have. I want to create it myself and
better. I don't know where to start.
Please ask me the questions to to know
what you need.
>> Are you still building to be SAS in 26?
Because if you're not even riding the AI
wave, what the [__] are you doing?
>> Forget about SAS. Build with AI. That's
it. I have a AI agent managing the AI
agents.
>> Yeah. AK. Open Clo.
>> AI 1, AI 2, AI 3.
>> Have you seen like the videos of like
Alex Finn when he has like a five agent
like doing the whole stuff? He has like
agent running 24/7.
>> But I think his agents are also hiring
agents. He said they agents were using
CHPD and cloud as well.
>> Yeah. I spent 20 grand on open claw.
Here's why. He vap coded an app to show
all of the agent and they are taking
meetings aka like they review each other
kind of cool and then he explain why
he's doing that all of the agent are
reading ready 24/7 like strategizing and
basically reviewing all of the content
cut the apps that if the AI think it's a
good vibe coding apps that can run
automatically ship it and then DM
original poster it's kind of cool
because for distribution that's a
killing
>> yeah but he spends a lot of money on his
Mac minis, but how much money is he
spending on tokens?
>> Then it it doesn't cost anything
anymore. But I have like two clothes cut
subscription which is like 400 a month
and but I don't run 247. But I use them
a lot.
>> Yeah. But even if you have three then
spending 10k on a Mac mini then $600
isn't that much.
>> Where is the value proposition?
>> Well, it was a few months ago and nobody
knows how fast it's going. It's insane.
>> You want to build a SAS.
that
>> not anymore. Well, you can, but then it
has to be like really, really, really
big. Like something so big that people
don't want to start on it and it's too
complex to just plan everything and you
need really hard knowledge to build
everything. But if it is something
simple, yeah, then you're screwed. Yeah.
>> You had to assess for just for
registering mileage on your car for for
your administration for the company. You
say where you are. You say again where
where you're stopped and it calculates
kilometers and puts it in your
administration. Well, all those SAS
companies I think they are going to
zero.
>> For us technical guys like we say, okay,
I'm going to v code that [__] in like a
weekend and then I will have like
multi-billion SAS too and I will I will
do a better job than Salesforce, right?
Yeah, you're right. Like Salesforce is
big. They it serve like million of
customers. So then it's it's harder to
to attack at the AI age and especially
when they like for example they have
created like the Salesforce SDR
Salesforce I forgot the name of exactly
the name but it's a AI sales guys like
they did like crazy sales number
>> for sure on the smaller companies who
are not so dependent on the integration
of Salesforce in all the systems.
>> Yeah. And have you ever tried
Salesforce?
>> Yeah. It's complex to set up
>> like Jesus. But yeah, I built my own
Zenesk and I did in three days and then
I took like while using it, I asked
cloud to create a new function, optimize
it, do it in a different way and within
two weeks it was exactly as I wanted to
have it.
>> Yeah.
>> And that was an expensive Zenesk
subscription.
>> Yeah. And plus like I know you can
include it to your customer subscription
and stuff like that. Like you can upsell
provide more value for Yeah.
>> AI bots integrated. They talk WhatsApp
business API integrated task creation
from tickets time integrated time
registration everything is integrated
and built by my own AI.
>> Would you offer classic SAS UI? Do you
think people will use conversational
chat like chat GPT experience in your
CRM for your customers?
>> Yeah, it depends on the user, right? We
will use like the chat GPT version but a
lot of people don't even know how to
write a proper prompt.
>> Yeah, 100%. And like okay so if you have
a conversational like you build a SAS an
agent first like agent first app what
the [__] do you ask basically
>> you can also turn it around right like
you tell to the AI hey this is what I
have I want to create it myself and
better I don't know where to start
please ask me the questions to
>> to know what you need
>> yeah but see that like saying ask me
questions to for you to get information
that's not that that it's not like we we
know how to do Ourel because we spent
the last 18 months with AI tools.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> My mom doesn't understand that.
>> Yeah. She ask you who's typing back.
>> Exactly. Yeah. I I I would be curious
like what's the first impression of
someone who like in the last three years
didn't touch GPT or do they interact
with the technology and like okay so you
don't you don't interact with CHP. We
are orchestrating AI already and it's
only going to get better. All of that to
say that our experience with AI is way
more technical than any normies. Even
like a project manager in a big
corporate or anyone who is working on a
desk
>> they need to manage a lot more than just
five AIs and we are doing AI full-time.
>> Okay. People use Salesforce and there is
like billions of [__] features on
Salesforce but at the end of the day you
pay like 10 grand a month and you use
three.
>> Yeah. Yeah. And the only other feature
that you need is in the 20k
subscription. That's always how it goes.
>> Yeah, but use another SAS or buy codes
as people you need.
>> Just say I need Salesforce the
enterprise solution build it.
>> Do you think Salesforce will have to cut
price of the monthly sub or yearly
contract to compete with AI?
>> Yeah. But can they eventually
>> I mean if they fire like 50% of their
workforce anywhere. Yes.
>> Yeah. Yeah. then it's no issue but they
need to do something I think
>> agent force it's a AIdriven platform
featuring autonomous agent that handle
revenue related task key revenue metrics
impact late 25 explosion AI growth agent
force and data 360 combined reach nearly
1.4 4 billion in annual revenue. Jesus
with 100% yearover-year growth. I know
to sell Salesforce.
>> Well, I think first the smaller SAS
companies are going down and then it
will take some time. But eventually the
big ones they have to adapt or just sync
with the rest.
>> Yeah. Like you at the top of the funnel
when like you are Sal force and you work
with government and big corp then you
save and the micro SAS can probably sell
to 10 customers, 20 customers and then
dies. For example, you have AI that can
maybe simplify the migration from
Salesforce to another vendor even for
like the big and hard solution to
migrate. Like for example, when you
subscribe to Salesforce, you are not a
customers. You you're a slave to
Salesforce because now your business is
completely integrated into it and you
can't leave it anymore. So you're going
to pay you're going to pay your bill for
the next 20 years and your bill is going
to 100x but you can leave anymore
because everything is in it right. So
maybe AI can also simplify the migration
from one tool to another. If you need a
consultant to migrate AI can help you
migrate like the biggest shift is people
will pay for the output of it no matter
what over like the all of the
consideration of like the SAS UX UI
business model. Like for example, having
a a seat business model like pay per
seat doesn't make sense anymore.
>> No, it just needs to get the the the job
done. So yeah, I think the conclusion is
SAS is not there. Not yet.
>> Yeah, not yet. Just wait.
>> Not yet.
>> We will redo the conversation in six
months.
>> So yeah, for everyone who has a
subscription, maybe you can keep it.
Maybe
>> maybe you hire us to just rebuild it.
>> Thank you everyone. And uh yeah, thank
you for watching the live